- [Instructor] So when I was younger,
around seven or eight years old,
I used to have a beta fish named Bob,
and he happened to be a blue-colored fish.
Now, I've always wondered
how he got his color.
So for example, were
his parents also blue?
Does he have any siblings that were blue?
So today, let's try to
answer in simple terms
how Bob gets his blue color.
And we'll start by defining genes.
Genes. What are genes?
Well, genes are basic hereditary units
that are well, first of all,
they are passed down
from parent to offspring.
So I'll write passed
down parent to offspring.
And they also contain information
about an organism's traits.
Contain info about an organism's traits.
So it would only make sense that since Bob
is a blue-colored fish,
that he must have a parent
or ancestor who is also blue-colored.
Now, a single kind of gene can
have many different versions,
and we call these versions alleles.
Alleles.
And these are just different
variations of a single gene.
So for example, there may be a gene
that provides information
about beta fish coloration.
So let me draw an arrow from
Bob to, we'll say, color gene.
And one allele of this gene may
lead to a blue-colored fish.
So I'll write here blue color.
And another allele may
lead to green coloration.
And I'll write here, next
to blue color, green color.
But physically, what are genes, exactly?
Well, genes are part of DNA
or deoxyribonucleic acid.
And I know, it's a really big word.
So let me write it out for us.
DNA. Deoxyribonucleic acid.
DNA.
So DNA is a macromolecule,
or a really big and complex molecule.
So when you hear macro, just
think big or complex molecule.
And you can also think of
DNA like a giant cookbook
of genetic information,
because that's what it is.
It is a cookbook of genetic information.
So here is a close-up sketch of DNA.
And what I'm showing
here is that DNA consists
of subunits called nucleotides.
Nucleotides.
And these are represented
by As, Ts, Cs, and Gs.
Now genes are like the individual recipes.
You can think of them as the recipes found
inside your DNA cookbook.
So they are specific
segments of nucleotides
within the long DNA molecule.
So a gene could be from here to here.
And we think of this as a recipe.
But what do these gene
recipes make anyways?
Well, many genes encode proteins,
which are made of long sequences
or chains of amino acids.
So, I'll write here under proteins
that proteins are made
of amino acid chains.
And genes provide instructions
for how to create these chains.
So thinking back to how
genes are like recipes
because each gene has a different set
of quote-unquote,
"ingredients", or in this case,
a different nucleotide sequence,
different genes would therefore
encode different proteins.
So proteins in this example,
if you want to continue
on with this analogy,
proteins would be like
the finished products
of your recipes.
Remember how I mentioned that alleles
are different versions of a specific gene?
Well, different alleles have
different nucleotide sequences
and are therefore likely to
also encode different proteins.
So I'll write under
here, different alleles,
and draw an arrow to different proteins.
So different genes and different alleles
can give us different proteins.
So of blue fish like Bob,
likely has a distinct allele
that encodes proteins, which
give him his natural blue color
or his natural blue shade.
Now, an organism has many different genes,
which means an organism has the capacity
to produce many different
kinds of proteins.
And proteins serve all kinds of functions,
some of which include
growth, sending messages,
oh, also catalyzing chemical reactions,
if you have heard of enzymes before.
So, I'll write catalyzing
chemical reactions
and providing structure.
Ultimately, it's the activity
of these different kinds of proteins
that help determine an
organism's physical traits,
just like how proteins can determine
the color of Bob the beta fish.
Now, you might be wondering too,
what genes do in the big picture.
For example, not all of the
cells in Bob the beta fish
function in the same way, right?
You could say that there
are different types
of cells that perform specific functions.
And this is known as cell specialization.
So cell specialization is when
different cells specialize
in different functions.
And each type of specialized cell
contains a unique combination of proteins
that give the cell its
specialized function
within an organism.
So I'll write here that
cell specialization
comes from unique combos of proteins.
And it's important to note
that every cell in an organism
contains the same genes.
So going back to Bob here,
we can say that all his cells contain
the same DNA and genetic information,
whether it's on his tail or in his eye,
but what makes their functions different
is which subset of genes are expressed
or used to build proteins
in the different cell types.
So, I'll write here, all of
the cells in Bob the beta fish
have the same DNA and genes,
just different protein combinations.
So today, we learned about
genes which are passed down
from parent to offspring,
just like how Bob the blue
beta fish got his color,
and they contain information
about organisms' traits.
So genes are parts of longer DNA molecules
and they consist of specific
segments of nucleotide bases.
So thinking back to our cookbook
and recipe analogy, right?
Genes can encode all kinds
of different proteins.
And it's this unique set of proteins
within each cell that gives
the cell its specific function
within the organism.
As we talked about with Bob the beta fish,
and all of the cells in Bob
having the same DNA and genes,
just different proteins.